Speaker 1: Well, we have a verdict in the
defamation trial of Infowars conspiracy
theorist Alex Jones, and it is $49 million
now. How much of it can actually be awarded per
Texas statutes is a separate question.
How much of it can or will be collected
by the plaintiffs is another question. But
this is the verdict regardless. Let's take
a look at the moment that the judge
read it out. Remember that there were
a $4 million in compensatory damages and then
we now get another 45 million in punitive
damages totaling nearly 40, just over $49 million.
Speaker 2: Question number one, $4,200,000.
Question number two $20,500,000. Question
number three $20,500,000. All right.
This question is addressed to my jury. Is
this your verdict? So say each and all of
you. Yes, sir. Thank you very much. Would
the attorneys like to examine the verdict?
Speaker 1: So there it is. Ladies and gentlemen,
Alex Jones, $49.3 million verdict as the Los
Angeles Times accurately points out. And one
of the things that Michael Sisak from the
Associated Press writes about is what does this
mean for the larger misinformation ecosystem,
a social media fueled world of election denial,
COVID skepticism and other dubious claims that
Alex Jones helped to build? Now, there are many
who are saying this is a defeat for so-called free
speech, but as I know many of you are aware, there
is not. How can we put this? I am aware that even
though I have my show and I have my microphone
and in a literal sense I can say whatever I want,
I can't just say anything and expect to
be free from the consequences of that.
If I were to start targeting a private citizen,
imagine that I had. Let's take the eggman,
for example. Our great caller, the eggman, who has
been calling in and listening for over a decade.
Imagine that I started giving out the egg man's
real name and saying things about him and making
all of these claims specifically about him. He's
just a private person who sometimes calls in and
doesn't even identify himself by his real name,
and it starts causing him problems at his job and
in his life and whatever. I would not expect that
if he sues me for defamation or doxing or whatever
else that I could just say it's free speech and
that's it. It would be absurd for me to think
that that would be a valid defense. Now, maybe the
things I say are or aren't defamatory. That's a
very specific question. And part of it is whether
they are true. But there are limits to what I can
do with my platform. I have a responsibility
on the platform not to do that. And so,
sure, when I go after Roger Stone, as we're about
to do a public person for things he publicly says,
that's one thing. But when you start saying the
victims of a mass shooting were actors, they they
didn't really die. The parents are in on it. Here
are specific parents who are in on it. That is not
free speech and it is not even with new law. Under
the existing infrastructure of defamation law and
other law, you're not allowed to do that. So this
is not about free speech. And there is a question
as to whether the doctors and the bullies
and all of them who do this for a living
are now potentially going to be in jeopardy
because of the same legal infrastructure.
Nothing new. No new law has been created
because of the same legal infrastructure
that may bring down Alex Jones. It's a real
question. We don't yet know the answer.